valentine's Day is fast approaching but
you don't have to wait until sunday for
some Grand Theft Auto treats rockstars
be my Valentine update for GTA online
launches today prepare for some new cars
and clothes like most GTA online updates
be my Valentine is only for ps4 xbox one
and pc making its debut is the alvin e
roosevelt valour which you can grab from
the legendary motorsports store the
standard albany roosevelt is also
returning from 2014's valentines event
swanky new outfits are also available to
purchase and all the clothes from
previous valentines updates are back to
you can also grab the gusenberg sweeper
machine gun if you're looking to cosplay
is John Dillinger be my Valentine is
also bringing a new adversary mode
called till death do us part which will
pit couples against each other we'll
learn more about that when Rockstar
releases it this friday for now enjoy
your slick suits and fancy cars and for
all the Grand Theft Auto news you
already in the right place
you